foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists Ryan is back again
yeah yeah we also have malabama here in
the studio hi everybody TK Coleman is
here what it is we got the rest of our
team as well coming up today on this
free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about decluttering
Facebook friends we also have an
outstanding lightning round listener tip
and added value segment for you you can
check out the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 359 where we answer
four times the questions and we dive
into seven simple living segments that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com the minimalists your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me y'all
advertisements suck
oh Alabama where are we starting today
let's start with our first question from
Lynn in Sweden
hi my name is Lynn and I live in Sweden
I'm a patreon subscriber I am longing to
declutter my Facebook friend list I have
previously done it on Instagram and I
found it much easier as I had a shorter
friend list there another factor is that
there are Facebook friends that I want
to keep in case I need to network with
them again in the future but in the same
time I really want to have a shorter
friends list on Facebook do you have any
tips or suggestions
I'm going to start with saying this that
a just in case friend isn't a friend at
all
a lot of people use things right not hey
maybe I need to use these people at some
point in the future now it doesn't mean
that we can't be useful to one another
everyone in this room we're useful for
each other and that's okay the problem
is when we develop these relationships
where it's uh you know what I better
have that relationship just in case I
need to use that person now I think
there are a few ways that we can
approach a question like this you can do
something like what I did versus
something like what Ryan did I'm sure TK
has some insights as well so the first
thing I did when I first left the
corporate world and I had over a
thousand Facebook friends because you
just let them accumulate not knowing
what's going on and then all of a sudden
you turn around you're like who is that
person wait I'm friends with this person
I've never even met it's a friend of a
friend of a friend of a Facebook friend
and now here I am with all of these
so-called friends and I know them
Loosely or maybe I don't even know them
at all or maybe there are some people
from my past where I don't need to keep
holding on to that relationship I can
let it go and so here's what I did I
just unfriended everyone
and then I added re-added the friends I
also unfollowed everyone on other
platforms like Twitter and eventually
I've done this again on Instagram we
didn't have Instagram at the time this
is back in 2011. as I unfriended
everyone and unfollowed them and then I
intentionally said who am I missing out
on who are the people who I actually
want to check in with their life
regularly and I re-friended them and
occasionally someone would ask me hey
why did you unfriend me oh you know what
I just unfriended everyone and that way
you have an easy out too I'd love to add
you back though because I want to keep
back up with your life now Ryan you did
something a little bit more extreme yeah
man um do you know how someone got rid
of Facebook
don't worry they'll tell you
yeah man I I got rid of it because it
was stressing me out too I mean I really
feel Len's uh pain here
um and and I would you know dare to say
that like I had way more pain like on on
a good day Facebook would pacify me on
its worst day it would ruin my day never
in my life did I ever go to bed thinking
Facebook added so much value today thank
you Facebook
um I uh yeah so I got rid of it and I'll
tell you it does make it does make uh
things a little bit more inconvenient
because there's a lot of haps going in
on Facebook I mean so there's like maybe
five percent of it that there is some
information on there that can help there
are some groups you can be part of I
know
um there's like a couple like The
Burning Man thing like there's a whole
you know group for our camp and I'm
missing out on all of that um and
there's some pertinent information on
there but here's what I know it's like
if there's really important information
on there they're gonna make sure I get
it yeah and I think that's important to
notice it's the fear of missing out
versus the joy of missing out now I will
say the reason the main reason I kept
Facebook was actually so I could be part
of a few small groups that required
Facebook membership and so I think
there's a Middle Road here where you can
get rid of your Facebook altogether have
a new account where you only follow two
or three groups that you really want to
follow I totally have like a um a burner
account yeah I have a burner account
though I got and it's funny because um
it's really for minimalist.org stuff
yeah so minimals.org is our free local
meetup groups we have a hundred meetup
groups in a hundred different cities
eight different countries also an online
line City you can find those at
minimalist.org so you can connect with
local open-minded or as TK would say
active-minded people and so part of
that's one of the groups that I'm a part
of is minimalist.org it's the main
reason I have a Facebook account and
there are two or three other groups that
Facebook is nice for but other than that
I just generally don't keep up with it
yeah I mean and I have that account
because
um you know Emma might call me up and be
like hey uh can you take a look at this
post and let me know what you think and
then you know I have a way to like kind
of get on there and and lurk a little
bit
um but yeah I mean I probably use it
once every couple months like I don't
use it much at all I will tell you
though my life when I got rid of
Facebook it was like this huge weight
that I took took off myself you know we
talk a lot about like we pick up these
Boulders we're like walking up this hill
and we we're picking up all these
Boulders and then all of a sudden we're
like oh my God why am I so tired and
stressed out what what's going on and
then you realize like oh like I I picked
this up I can also put this down and
when I put that down um my life wasn't
at least it was at least five percent
better and why why is that why do you
feel like it was causing so much stress
for you because I think that well first
off Facebook is a very fake World
Facebook is is is full of
um uh hyperbole exaggerations
um I don't I don't know how else to say
it but like bipartisan politics yeah and
so I see family members
that like I saw a family member um
basically post some meme about and this
is really what like kind of triggered my
thought of like oh I gotta get off here
this family member posted something
about like if you voted for this person
you shouldn't be able to breed like this
was the meme and I'm like
she would never say that to anyone's
face
she would never she would never say that
to my face she would never say it's a
your face like she's a very nice woman
but on Facebook all of a sudden you've
got like you've got a little bit less of
uh I don't know what it is like because
you're not looking at someone face to
face so you have a little bit of less
trepidation to say something that's
going to be offensive in fact I think
Facebook encourages you to like yell and
be loud and to and to voice your opinion
in a way that you normally wouldn't do
it face to face and to me that's toxic
and I and I really started to um yeah I
just really started to kind of look at
because some friends I was like oh my
God like I can't believe like they
actually feel this way like I don't even
want to hang out with him anymore yeah
like it was damaging relationships when
if I wasn't on Facebook relationship
wouldn't be damaged at all that's a
great Point yeah Ricky Gervais says
going on to Twitter or Facebook is like
reading a bunch of comments in a bunch
of different bathroom stalls yes and
then pretending that's real life that's
so good that's so good that's so good
yeah I think we underestimate just how
much we lose from like real world human
interaction when we go online when we go
online we only talk about the things
that are fitting for being online which
are controversies and debates and and
things along those lines so that's
really interesting it's just like so
it's so emotional like Facebook is by
far the most emotional
um social media uh uh app out there like
I mean because Instagram I don't pick
that up I mean sometimes I get it a
little bit
um you know in my feed sometimes I get a
little bit and my feed on Twitter but
like Facebook is like everyone's either
like extremely happy yeah hashtag
blessed they're extremely sad I'm sad
today don't ask why or they're extremely
angry like it's it's all the emotions
and it's all the extreme emotions and
it's all Facebook to me is like the most
and I know Instagram is still Facebook
technically I call it I call it Facebook
Lite
um but yeah it's like Facebook to me is
like the the place where people are just
I've never seen so many people vying for
so much attention in my life and it's
again like it's really it's sad to like
see people like for some reason they
feel like they need that look at me look
at my problems or look at my joy I'm
happier than you when you said uh well
you said hashtag bless you made me think
about the comedian Gary Owen who says we
really just need to stop abusing that
we're blessed he asked one of his
friends he's like hey man how you doing
and this buddy goes I'm blessed just
getting up on these hoes
bro we just we should just put blessed
put bless to rest yeah so we got to stop
abusing that but I want to bring it home
that's good uh with respect to this
question it sounds like you know what
your gut is telling you to do and it's
not a question of what should I do but
how should I deal with the fear that
accompanies it and I'm afraid of missing
out when it comes to the possibilities
for networking and here's what I'll say
if you can't do business with someone
without pretending to be their friend
then that's a sign that you probably
shouldn't be doing business with them in
the first place
when it's time for networking people
don't mind you being direct and talking
about business what makes it offensive
is not when you are aren't friends with
someone but when you Ambush them by
pretending to be friends what's
offensive is when you call someone up
and you say hey man how are the kids
how's the wife how things been going
yeah uh-huh uh-huh okay so look I was
hoping you could sponsor my event and
the other person is thinking oh so this
is the real reason why you called and it
makes the you know the game of
friendship feel pretentious but if you
just call someone or email someone and
say hey haven't talked in a while but I
remember we connected at the conference
last year and you said something about
XYZ I think you'd be great for our event
and I'd be interested in knowing if it's
something you'd like to have a phone
call about for 10 minutes people are
okay with doing business when you're
direct it's what they're not okay with
is when you pretend to be friends when
you're actually not it reminds me of
this key and peel skit by the way where
these two black guys go to a bar are and
there's a white person that sits next to
them and says you know slavery was
[ __ ] man it was [ __ ] and the two
of them look at each other they're like
yeah it was and then uh another white
person comes from sitting next to them
and they're like you know I just want to
let you guys know
just on behalf of a lot of people out
there you know I'm just really sorry I'm
really sorry you know how hard you guys
have it and they're like oh okay thanks
and then finally there's this white guy
that comes to the bar and he like sits a
little further away from them and he's
like sorry I'm not comfortable around
black people and they look at each other
they go thank you
so even though this guy was being a
little bit insensitive or a lot a bit
insensitive they were they found his
authenticity so refreshing that they
just wanted to sit there and have a beer
with that guy that's a stretch that's an
extreme illustration but when it comes
to networking you don't need to be
friends with everyone that you need to
do business with you just need to be
authentic so don't be afraid to unfriend
those just in case friends when you need
people to do deals with if they're worth
doing deals with you can reach out to
them directly transparently
non-pretentiously and they'll look to
they'll look forward to connecting with
you man I'd love to send you a copy of
our book The minimalist rule book it's
16 rules for living with less because
you talked about just in case friends we
have something in there the just in case
Rule and 15 other rules that we simplify
our lives with if you want you can
download for free the minimalists.com
rulebook or if you want the audiobook
version we'll be happy to send that to
you as well Ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments your compliments
on Josh's hair
man I've missed that so much by the way
I've missed that so much it's so good to
have you back oh so good that phone
number by the way is
937-202-4654 and that goes to both of
our phones and pretty soon TK we gotta
get you set up on that remind me that
later today because you can just respond
to people whenever you want and we
actually respond to some folks here on
the podcast so you can text us whatever
you'd like during the lightning round
this is what Ryan TK and I do our best
to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response Professor Sean puts one minute
on the clock for us we give you our
minimal maxims by the way they're also
in the show notes so you can copy and
share or pithy answers on social media
if you like and now you can find all of
our minimal maxims in one place thanks
to our good friends social Jess that's
minimalmaxims.com Alabama Grace has a
question for us what are the best
strategies or ways to encourage our
partners to embrace minimalism and
simplicity TK Coleman has 60 seconds on
the clock
wow
the best testimony is a well-lived life
if you want to make a compelling case
for something that you believe and its
capacity to positively impact others the
best way for you to do that is to show
people what it looks like to live out
the value of those ideas create
curiosity about what you believe by the
way you behave if you're doing it right
people should be coming to you saying
hey what have you been reading what have
you been eating that's what I do to Ryan
he comes in here body don't lie I look
at that body and I say hey man where
have you been working out oh he doesn't
have to preach it to me he practices it
so well it creates curiosity that makes
me come to him that's what happens when
you live a good testimony oh keep going
give them another 30 seconds let me tell
you more about Ryan's beautiful body
with the five seconds I have left his
body is so amazing
all right let's start 60 seconds on the
clock for Ryan Nicodemus this is the
nicest way I've ever heard anyone ask
how do I make my partner a minimalist
um my fifth answer is this support Bound
by expectations isn't supportive so you
know another way to say uh to say this
too is hey you know the uh if you are
respecting your partner's preferences
whatever they may be minimalist or no
minimalist like that is going to be the
best invitation for them to respect your
preferences but if you are gonna if
you're gonna if you're gonna support
them if you're asking us like oh what
can I do to support them to be a
minimalist well now we're saying well if
you do these three things your partner's
gonna start to see the light and they're
going to start to come around that
corner yeah and that's just that's not
uh well it's not it's not accurate
because we have no advice to do that and
the other thing too is like well now
when that expectation isn't met well now
you're going to be doubly disappointed
yeah yeah how can I manipulate my
partner in a way right I'm using Ryan's
last nine seconds
but that's what in a way that's what we
asked that what are the strategies to
manipulate my partner to make them
better throw a minute on the clock for
me I got something to pithy for you here
the Y2 is infinitely more powerful than
the howl to quite often we want these
strategies what are the six things I can
do to manipulate my partner and
obviously Grace I don't think you're
trying to manipulate your partner you
want them to live a healthier life a
better life you want less suffering in
their life and that's why I get so
passionate about things like minimalism
or when we talk about diet we talk about
letting go we talk about love I get
passionate about these things because
I've suffered so much in my own life and
how have I suffered because I've been
chasing all of these how to's and they
never got me anywhere I chased all of
these solutions that ended up being a
bigger part of the problem but if I
truly understand the why to
what are the benefits of simplifying and
how can your partner change if they
truly understand what the benefits are
not the benefits benefits for you Grace
what are the benefits for your partner
and if they understand the benefits then
they will understand how to let go what
does Becca's shirt say coercion is not
consent yes yes keep that in mind when
you're working with your partner too but
I guess our new hip-hop song right here
is reset the clot I got something bite
deflated reset the clock I got something
the way you said it he was just so
rhythmic man you should say Pisces from
now on like just keep it keep it man
that could be another rap song
podcast Sean said him all the whole like
Greek etymology of the word pithy and
yeah anyway uh Malibu we've got so much
more to talk about
but first what do you got for us here's
a minimalist Insight from one of our
listeners
hello my name is Maggie and I'm from
Northport Michigan I wanted to leave a
comment addressing gifts I recently saw
a local news story about a little girl
who loved dogs so she asked for birthday
gifts such as dog food and toys that
would then be donated to their local
animal shelter
so then I thought for Mother's Day
um you could ask for items that then
could be donated to the local women's
shelter also around Christmas there's
usually toy drives and winter coat and
boot drives and the last idea for
children is their classroom at school
being adopted to supply with some basic
items that their class could need
all right y'all before we get to our
added value segment real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalists
actually two quick things our friends
over at Spire media we've been working
on this for a while and they finally got
it done we did a new design for my
personal website and I don't know why I
even have a website except thousands of
people visited every month joshuafields
milburn.com it basically just redirects
you to everything at the minimalists but
if you want to go check that out you can
but I'm much more excited about how to
write better.org Professor Sean and I
have been working on this for a while
you can see the new series that I've
been working on it's a 10 video series
called bad writing where we take popular
books and point out some of the best
most prolific authors still have bad
writing in some of their books and it's
okay it's not a judgment it's not say
they're bad writers we're all subjects
to bad writing at some point in time and
so you can find that over there at
howtoritebetter.org you can find the
video series there you can find the free
ebook to download as well 15 way ways to
write better for added value this week
Ryan this album you're really going to
enjoy it you know how I know sometimes I
rarely do I say Ryan's going to like
this music but it's nostalgic even
though it's new the band is called the
midnight and the album which just came
out is called Heroes and the song you're
hearing in the background right now
it is called change your heart or die
and I feel like Axel Rose should be
singing it it is so nostalgic It Feels
So 1980s and Bex and I were driving
around last weekend and she couldn't
stop singing We got out of the car and
Ella was there too and she was change
your heart or die there could not stop
singing this song it is the definition
of an ear worm so I think you'll enjoy
that if you're listening to the public
version of the podcast you'll hear it in
the background if you're watching the
public version on YouTube then you'll
see the YouTube link somewhere above my
left shoulder or if you're watching the
maximal episode on patreon then you get
to hear the whole thing see the whole
thing by the way TK we got a bunch more
surprise questions on the private
podcast this week like is it possible to
be a minimalist and a prepper at the
same time how do you let go of memories
that bring you misery and pain
what does a minimalist budget look like
for Joshua and Ryan plus a million more
questions for the minimalists and if
they want to hear all that in Alabama
tell them what to do check out the
minimalist private podcast visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal links so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you'll also gain
immediate access to all of our archives
recordings of Live Events weekly home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you in fact here's a thoughtful
testimonial from one of our lovely
private podcast supporters
Laurie says one of the many aspects I
enjoy about your private podcast is your
emphasis on portraying yourselves with
honesty you show us who you are not who
you wish you were that keeps you
relatable to all the rest of us
imperfect humans we are who we are and
it turns out we are in good company Ryan
you're so relatable dude you know it's
funny one of the things from one of the
principles from burning man is radical
acceptance and on the private podcast we
just talked about Ryan's whole Burning
Man experience we spent a few minutes on
it but it's interesting because uh yeah
man I mean that's something that um
radical self-acceptance and like that is
something that it took me a long time to
get there but man once you have that
like it's so freeing because you can't
be yourself and I'm so glad we get to do
that so thanks patrons for letting us be
ourselves thanks for your comment Lori
if you have a question or comment for
our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast the minimalist.com you can
follow the minimalists on Tick Tock
Instagram Facebook and Twitter at the
minimalists to get our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list at themenimalist.com that's
our show for today y'all on behalf of
Ryan Nicodemus TK Coleman Alabama
podcast Sean Jordan no more Professor
Sean social Jess Danny unknown
post-production Peter Emma The Immigrant
and the rest of our team I'm Joshua
Fields Milburn if you leave here today
with just one message let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time peace
foreign
[Music]
[Music]